[Music]
so when i was invited to give a tutorial
or the lecture at the summer school i
was told to talk about the modern
architectures of in deep learning and i
realized that the in fact surprisingly
so
the
neural net architecture hasn't really
evolved that much ever since 2017 or 18
when we started to use attention
everywhere uh instead i thought okay
let's try to think of a case where we
can view many different let's say
perspectives into training deep neural
networks uh from a perspective of the
neural net network architecture and the
idea what would be the best way to
demonstrate that i thought was the hyper
primary tuning which is another way to
look at optimization or you know the the
network architecture but from in one
level up
so today's lecture is going to be about
the online hyper primary tuning and i
want it to be as interactive as possible
i understand that online setup is very
difficult for any lecture to be
interactive but i'm going to i do have a
recording of this particular lecture
it's going to be not it's not going to
be exactly the same that i can share
with all the students later so that they
can review it so you know if you have
any questions as i go about because i'm
going to cover a lot of background
materials do ask and then search will be
able to
relay the questions for me and then i
can answer all of them
so when i think about the optimization
or the network architecture or whatever
you want deep learning uh
i i always imagine four different stages
one is a preparation because at the end
of the day what is the most important
thing is to prepare data properly and
then prepare what kind of models that
we're going to use are the kind of
optimization algorithms we're going to
use properly and then after the
preparation is done we actually do have
a two stages of optimization in the
first stage which we often refer to as
training we pick one particular modal
architecture network architecture or the
one particular hyper primary
optimization or i'm going to just refer
to all of them collectively as a
hypothesis said and then trying to find
the solution within this hypothesis set
that's going to have the minimum average
uh training loss
and then that's the second stage of the
training and then after that is done of
course it was the optimization problem
in the third stage that is called often
referred to as modal selection we solve
yet another optimization problem where
we're going to look at multiple
hypothesis sets and there could be as
many hypotheses you want and we're
trying to find the one
of which the solution corresponds to the
minimum validation loss or the average
validation loss
after the model selection is done we are
done with the optimization and then we
are we enter the stage the last stage of
reporting so we need to report or tell
other people who are going to use our
model how well this model is going to
work and then for that we are going to
simply compute the average test loss and
then report it together with our model
and today i'm going to focus on these
two stages the stage 2 and the stage 3
that are all about optimization
now training already most of you already
know yourself and then you probably have
learned about it from the three earlier
lectures of this summer school for
training we almost exclusively use
stochastic gradient descent or a variant
of stochastic gradient descent and in
stochastic gradient descent we try to
find the classifier that is parametrized
with theta their
theta which refers to collect to the
collection of the parameters so in the
case of the neural network we have a
very large neural network and then we
have all those weight values and then
all those wave values are going to be
referred to collectively as theta
and then we often need a differentiable
per example loss function l so for each
of the example in the training set we
want to know how well this classifier's
prediction is with respect to the ground
truth y and then we want this per
example loss function together with a
classifier to be differentiable with
respect to the parameters of this
network so we don't care whether it's
differentiable with respect to the
ground truth label y or the input x but
with respect to parameters we want it to
be jointly differentiable
and we often need to have a
differentiable regularizer such as a
weight decay or whatnot that's going to
ensure that the our hypothesis set is
properly regularized or limited so that
we are going to avoid overfitting to a
training set without generalizing to a
new examples
and why is this stochastic gradient
decent because if you have if you have
noticed then in fact computing this
function or the gradient of this loss
function the entire loss function with
respect to the parameters is extremely
expensive
what do i mean by that we need to be we
need to evaluate how good this
classifier is for every single training
example every time we compute the
gradient of this loss function and then
that's simply not scalable in particular
in this era of so-called big data we
have datasets that has often let's say
millions if not billions of instances
and if we have to go through billion
different examples every time we make a
tiny update to the parameters that's not
really what we want to do nor we can
afford to do so so instead we have to be
stochastic and then say that if we will
use a very small mini batch at a time
and then compute the gradient of this
mini batch loss function to do so we all
we need to all we need to do is evaluate
this function f or the neural network as
many times as there are examples in this
new batch alone that this mean batch
size can be as small as one two
sometimes several thousand only and then
compared to let's say millions or
billions that we are talking about over
the size of the trainings that we talked
about it's pretty reasonable we can we
can manage it right
and then when we do so uh we need to
think about what kind of hyperparameters
there are so these uh such as the
learning rate and regularization
coefficient i'm going to refer to them
as the optimization parameters because
these hyper parameters directly
influence how the optimization happens
of course there are many different hyper
primary such as the size of the network
like the width of the each of the layers
depth of the network and so on but you
know my sense is that if we just make
the network as large as we can uh
considering the memory requirement and
the compute requirement and then all
that matters is to find the good
hyperparameters for the optimization
procedure
now
one really interesting thing
one really interesting thing about
stochastic gradient this this and then
this optimization hyperparameter is that
it turned out that the choice of the
optimization hyperparameters
turned out to influence the solution
that we find
very very significantly what that means
is that
even though our loss function is fixed
so our loss function is given depending
on what kind of hyper parameters we use
for optimization
we may not be able to reach some of the
solutions while we end up and adopted
you know some certain set of the
solutions that that are ritual
so for instance if we start with a very
high learning rate
at the beginning then we might end up
with a well generalized solutions
however
if we start with a very low learning
rate regardless of what kind of
scheduling we set we are very likely to
end up with the non-generalizing
solutions and then this kind of
observation says uh this kind of
observation has been made multiple times
over the past few years and then some
have explained it from the perspective
of so-called implicit regularization and
then some others have uh approached it
from the
from the lens of the importance of the
early stage of learning
but i don't really care i don't really
care what the underlying causes are but
the important thing to notice here is
that the optimization hyper parameters
such as the learning rate how you set
them will change what kind of solutions
you're going to find or what kind of
neural net you're going to end up with
at the end
so what that means is that the assuming
that we're going to use a as large
neural net as possible be it
transformers be it confidence or to be
multi-layered perception with all those
fully connected layers if you use a
large network and then all that remains
is for us to choose a good set of
optimization hyper parameters such as a
learning rate regularization
coefficients and whatnot
and then to do so we now enter the third
stage that is model selection and in
modal selection which is often solved as
a black box optimization what we do is
we're going to go through all possible
optimization hyper parameters
and then for each setup we are going to
train this neural net entirely take the
final solution and then evaluate this
final solution on a validation set that
is separate from the training set it's
very important to use a separate
validation set that is not training set
and then once we evaluate it
each and every optimization hyper
parameters we're going to pick one that
has the lowest validation loss and this
often solves this black box optimization
as i said earlier because it's just so
expensive
to train the entire model so that is the
evaluation one-time evaluation of this
loss function that is a validation loss
function is very expensive because
every time we evaluate this validation
loss function we need to train the
entire neural network and then as i said
earlier we are assuming that we're going
to use as large neural net as we can
so what are the some of the standard
approaches to this modal selection or
the black box optimization that is used
to choose the right optimization hyper
parameters the first one you can imagine
is grid search we're going to simply
look at all possible optimization hyper
parameters make a grid in the space of
the optimization of parameters and then
evaluate every possible uniformly spaced
point in this space of the optimization
hyperparameters it's quite standard you
know that because it's available in
scikit-learn unfortunately it does not
scale well with the number of hyper
parameters because of the cursive
dimensionality you know we learned about
cursive dimensionality an introduction
to machine learning combinatory
optimization all those places and then
you know this is where we really really
literally run into the curse of
dimensionality in practice the number of
the uniformly spaced points that we need
to evaluate in order to exactly solve
this grid search grows exponentially
with respect to a number of optimization
hyper parameters so this is not really
what we want to use
and the interesting thing is that
it turned out a one of the simplest
possible solutions to address this issue
of the curse of dimensionality has been
to simply use
a random search
so we're going to
select a random set of hyper primary
strong uniformly or the look uniformly
from this hyperparameter space and then
evaluate all those randomly drawn points
and choose the one that has the lowest
validation loss now to be strict there's
absolutely no reason why this should
work better than research
without assuming certain thing about the
underlying loss function itself however
in practice it turned out that for
training neurons or you know the
selecting the hyperparameters for
neurotrading neural nets this one works
pretty well this is perhaps one of the
most cited papers in the field of deep
learning that is uh berkshire and banjo
2012
that came out of montreal
of course we can do better so whenever
you talk to people and then they tell
you that yeah we're solving this uh
difficult optimization problem with uh
random search product research you can
always tell them that oh we can solve
better and then one way in which we can
solve better this kind of black box
optimization problems is so called
sequential model based optimization so
instead of trying to evaluate all the
points
and then just use those pointwise
information that we get for every
evaluation in sequential model based
optimization we're trying to fit a model
that's going to look very similar to the
underlying underlying loss function
validation loss function using as few a
number of evaluation or the points as
possible
now what is the requirements for this
model this model shouldn't just tell us
how
how each of the points should evaluate
to or the correspond to the certain
validation loss but it should also tell
us given any other point what the
uncertainty is
so we want to know what are the points
in this hyperparameter space
for which we know the actual validation
also and also we want to know how
certain our knowledge about this
validation loss is and then using these
two information that is that what is the
average validation loss i can expect
from a particular point and how certain
my prediction of this average validation
loss is at that point now i can balance
them in order to explore the space of
the hyper parameters or the optimization
hyper parameters to be specific
much better or much more efficiently
now you know like of course i i can go
into the details about the whole thing
but it's going to take up
probably multiple lectures so my
suggestion is to go look at the brochure
l 2010 and then that's a pretty
accessible tutorial that i really
enjoyed reading to learn about the
sequential model-based optimization
now in the context of machine learning
or deep learning or
even more specifically optimization and
deep learning bayesian optimization with
gaussian process has been a one of the
factor standard in uh such a sequential
model based optimization for modal
selection already optimization hyper
primary selection this was put forward
as a proposal in 2015 by snook l and
it's a very uh
beautiful way to solve this problem you
know
so everything that all the machine
learning people love kind of come in
there's a gaussian process there's a
bayesian let's say treatment there is
the active learning component and yet
there's an uncertain quantification it's
pretty beautiful and then it's become
pretty much uh at the factor standard in
particular last year if i remember
correctly there was a competition in
eurips about the black box optimization
bayesian optimization with gaussian
process was one of the winning entries
or if not the evening entry and then you
can use it quite easily nowadays you can
just use this i can optimize and then
together with the cycle learn and then
it's going to find all those nice hyper
primers for you are very cool
now that was good but what is the one
thing that all these people who have
been teaching and who are going to teach
at this tip learning deep learning and
reinforcement learning summaries called
love
is gradient-based optimization and
unfortunately what we noticed was that
the training part so the the half of the
optimization and deep learning
we now know how to solve it very very
well with the gradient-based tuning or
the gradient beta optimization but the
other half the modal selection part
we we really haven't used the
gradient-based optimization there and
then it's been always treated as a black
box optimization
obviously uh because we all love it
people have worked on gradient-based
hyper primary tuning for some time and
i'm going to go through some of these uh
now but let's see oh i see there is a q
a let's see there there are a couple of
questions let me try to answer them
before i move on because this is a
perfect time to answer some of the
questions
so let's see
i see a question from
luz angelica
what's the full reference for the
brochure 2010 tutorial on sequential
model-based optimization oh yes sir i
mean i can't really recall the title but
if you google brochure 2010 sequential
model based optimization you're going to
definitely find it uh if not i'll try to
actually share this slide after this
talk but then
there i'm going to email it to the
organizers some of the papers that i
think are important or the interesting
to read for you to easily refer to later
after the lecture
the second question is by arfan mia
miyahi that's does bayesian optimization
scale well with the number of
hyperparameters
so no black box optimization algorithms
without any assumptions
of the underlying function will scale
well with the number of hyper parameters
because you can always come up with a
loss function that just cannot be solved
well
without knowing the curvature
information but
at least for the case of the hyperprimer
tuning and whatnot uh at least united
personally i've had a good experience
using based on optimization for tuning
many hyper primers like the layer wise
learning rate and whatnot
of course you know the i believe there
will be few other people at the summer
school who are much more experts in base
and optimization than i am so you should
ask them about it
um let me see
so let's see one last question before i
move on to the gradient-based
hyperparameter tuning by the anonymous
attendee could you give an example of
acquisition function in smbo
um so let's say so there are a lot of
the acquisition functions and then it
turned out that the choosing or
designing the acquisition function
itself is a bit more of an art than
science but one of the things that
people have used or the kind of standard
one that everyone learns is the upper
confidence bound so or the lower
confidence bond i i don't know what's
the right way to say it but that is the
diff i want to choose a point that's
going to have a very low loss but at the
same time has a high enough uncertainty
so that the i hit the balance between
exploitation that is fine the low
validation loss but also i tried the
points that i'm not entirely sure yet
whether there is a good solution or not
so this one is like the whole let's say
lectures that can be done and then
obviously i'm not the most um
qualified one to do so you know they ask
let's say srs and many others who are at
the summer school later on
oh and then there is a one short
question i'm going to answer this one
before i move on to guardian-based
hyper-primary tuning the question is can
the mini-batch size be interpreted as a
hyper parameter yes indeed it can be
interpreted as hyper parameters but just
like the network architecture or the
size of the network i do believe that
this is often a good idea to make the
network neural net network as large as
possible or you know as much as you can
afford and then use a mini batch size
that again you can afford as much as you
can although my uh
my sense or my sense is that the
size of the mini but shouldn't matter
that much i know that that's not true uh
in practice especially when we train
transformers and whatnot i almost feel
like that's just an issue with the
natural architecture or the loss
function itself rather than the size of
the mini branch but this is a highly
very much open question thanks for the
question
oh and then uh thanks uh adriana uh
who actually answered my question uh the
the first question on my behalf so i'm
going to read out the title of the
brochure so it was a paper titled a
tutorial on bayesian optimization of
expensive cost functions with
application to active user modeling and
hierarchical reinforcement learning and
was authored by proshu cora and the
freires
so if you think about this model
selection and learning you notice that
it is stages two and three can be just
merged into a single by level
optimization problem so there is our
optimization that is the usual model
selection but what we notice here is
that the
one particular part of this outer
optimization that is the theta head of
the lambda is in fact the solution
a solution from solving the inner
optimization problem that is training a
neural network so i'm going to just
refer to it as bi-level optimization for
now
the reason why i refer to it as by level
optimization just for now is that it
turned out in practice it's actually not
a bi-level optimization so let's imagine
the idea what is how we are solving this
inner optimization problem that is to
minimize the average training loss with
respect to the parameters of a neural
network that is theta so we're going to
start initializing this theta with a
theta zero sen are drawn from a sum
distribution that we think are supposed
to be good for initializing these neural
networks there are so many of them that
are being done like the
you probably
have heard about the glory
initialization you probably have heard
about the whole initialization
you probably have heard of how pytorch
initialized things tensorflow initialize
things and then somehow everyone has
their own way of initializing these
parameters
once the initialization is done we are
going to use stochastic gradient
decentralized variants such as atom in
order to
update these parameters little by little
so we're going to compute theta t given
theta t minus 1 and this update
direction that is computed using a
minima time step t and the parameters
from the previous time step theta t
minus 1.
and after some time
after some time
even if the optimization has not been
solved perfectly we're going to just
stop we often stop it based on various
uh criteria including the only stopping
based on the validation loss or we're
going to just stop it because we ran out
of time or we're going to stop it
because we notice that the change the
loss value is within some tolerance that
uh
tolerance that we pre predefined earlier
so what that means is that we actually
never find the fixed point of this
optimization problem but we just stop it
at some point
that is reasonable
and what we notice here is that the uh
with this we notice that this whole
stochastic gradients are actually
differentiable with respect to lambda
that is the optimization of
hyperparameter so rather than solving
the inner optimization problem we could
imagine that we just ui did write out a
very very long and then complicated
procedure
to extend the validation loss function
and then this validation loss function
that includes this training procedure of
a finite number of steps is
differentiable not only with respect to
the primary theta itself but also
differentiable with respect to the
optimization hyperprimary such as
learning rate and regularization
coefficient
and what that means is that
we can now treat the whole thing as a
single optimization problem so we just
collapse the outer and you know look
into one optimization problem and as it
was noticed by joshua in 2002 not 2020
there's a typo that i just never
get to fix it
so you collapse these two optimization
process procedures and you get just one
optimization problem now the problem
with this one optimization problem is
that
this function the loss value the
validation loss we use is extremely
extremely expensive
you can imagine you know why it's
expensive you're just training you train
the entire neural network for a finite
number of time but that is reasonable
and then we're trying to
evaluate the final solution so it is
very expensive but still because the
whole procedure of training is
differentiable with respect to the
optimization hyperprimary lambda we can
always use the back propagation and then
use the gradient-based optimization in
order to find the optimization
hyperprimary setup setting to minimize
the validation loss
unfortunately it's very expensive not
only due to the forward pass so that is
that the training but because of back
propagation through this back back
propagation procedure the training
procedure requires computing
multiple copies in fact as many copies
of the hessian matrix
as the number of the updates we have
taken in training this neural network
now obviously we don't need to get in
we don't need to compute the explicit uh
compute the hessian matrix explicitly
but all we need is a hexane matrix times
some vector that's the only thing that
we need unfortunately that is still
expensive and we have to do that every
time we made one update to the neural
network
so it's super duper expensive you can
imagine and that is for one tiny update
to the validation uh the optimization
hyperparameters
what that means is that uh we need some
kind of approximation
and then we by doing so we need to make
some appropriate tradeoff so you know
three different approaches have been
tested and proposed and tested one way
is that you just say that okay we don't
really care about
training the neural net all the way and
then see how that neural net does in
terms of validation laws we're going to
simply say all we need to do is look at
the few steps of training and then
that's enough for us to figure out what
the what is the good what are good um
what a good optimization of parameters
the second approach is
relying on so-called implicit function
theorem which is
uh conceptually similar to truncated
backdrop through backdrop that is that
if we're going to go all the way until
the
convergence or you know until the
training is over and then we're going to
assume that
well at this point we're going to simply
assume that the training loss function
looks really really nice and then we are
going to look at only a last one step or
the few steps in order to approximate
this training loss function and then use
that information to approximate what the
jacobian of the
final solution with respect to the
optimization hyperparameters would have
been
this one actually works well it was
actually proposed in 2000 by yahshua
banjo and then this idea was revived in
2016 and then idr this idea is used for
various purposes ever since
and then the final one is the reversible
iterative optimization we give up on the
ip reducing the computation but we can
at least reduce the amount of the memory
that is needed because if you think
about the amount of memory that is
required in order to go all the way
until the end of the training and then
back prop all the way back it's actually
pretty gigantic but then if the
optimization algorithm was designed or
selected so that their every step is
reversible then you don't have to save
all those intermediate steps and that
allows us to
compute this uh gradient a backdrop by
backward gradient or the gradient of the
gradient
exactly without having to suffer from
the memory overhead
and as you can imagine you can mix and
match all these different things uh in
fact this this is a table coming out of
the loreno 2020 of my favorite table
because it was actually it really
summarizes what people have tried and
then what are the things that uh what
kind of computation complexity we have
and then what are the approximation that
is being done this is really nice and
the table and then the paper is really
nice i highly recommend you to read it
but what you notice in general is that
there is a clear tradeoff between the
computational complexity or even the
computational tractability and the
quality of approximation so in order to
get a good quality we often have to
spend a lot on computation including
memory and then if you want to save on
computation we often have to sacrifice
the quality of approximation
and in that case uh we i wanted we
wanted to see can we actually do better
than this
so this is what current practice is and
then we want to
see if you can do it a bit differently
than what a lot of most of the people
have done although it turned out that
the few other people have done the idea
what i'm going to tell you about but
we'll get to that soon before that let's
say there is one question
oh charlie go there okay so the can you
post the name of the paper in the chat
in order for us to copy paste
good point i'll try to look it up and
i'll send you all the lists of the
papers that were referred to during my
lecture after the talk is done yes sorry
about that
one another question from erfan miyahi
are any of these bi-level optimization
techniques
suitable for optimizing the neural
network
um
well it's a it's the present question
so it's difficult to tell you know idea
what it means to optimize the neural
architecture if you're asking whether we
can use uh by level optimization which
is what we are doing like do we have a
separate hyper primary selection to
optimize the neural net architecture yes
that's what we all know people are
working on quite uh heavily and then
that's what essentially cochlea has been
working on at google for the past four
years trying to use a various techniques
or trying out all possible techniques
and you may you can imagine to find the
best network architecture or the
primitives that are going to minimize
the loss validation loss function but
it's very difficult problem the reason
why it's difficult is a
extremely high dimensional combinatorial
space that is the neural net
architecture space and then there is not
a clear
kind of inductive bias that we can rely
on in order to tell what are is what are
the similar architectures in terms of
the actual generalization if we knew
that we could actually bake that in as a
heuristic for solving these
combinational optimization algorithms
but when it comes to neuron and
architecture i don't think we have a
good such you know intuition what those
you know i think right right metrics are
in this space
uh let me see yes uh human neural
architecture search i hope i hopefully i
answered it already and then final
question before we go into the slightly
newer thing by anonymous tendi uh can
you please go back to which method was
the current practice arrow pointing to
oh i'm sorry about this so the
everything that i've talked about so far
is the current practice
that's what everyone has been doing
that's what everyone has proposed to do
so and then that's what a lot of people
have tried and are using every day
so instead let's see if we can actually
think about a different way to
solve it and then to do so we're going
to think about we're going to talk about
a different perspective to think about
what a learning what learning is
so if we look at the inner optimization
there is training based on the
stochastic gradient decent what we can
think of is that it creates a
computational graph
so at every time step t we start with
the theta t minus one that is the
previous parameters
and then given this theta t minus one
we're going to compute the update delta
and then this delta t takes us input
theta t minus 1 as well as the mean of
edge a minimum edge of example set times
f t b t
and this whole function delta is
parameterized using this optimization
hyperparameter is lambda
once this delta is computed we are going
to add this delta so the update
direction to the theta t minus 1 in
order to result in theta t and then this
whole procedure
happens over and over and over
and then how where do we start we start
from the initial parameters theta zero
let's put that aside let's think about a
recurrent neural network uh hopefully
you're all i'm familiar with the
recurring neural network or maybe you
know i did not anymore i guess everyone
is just using transformer these days but
recurrent unless are pretty cool so
let's just look at it very briefly a
recurrent neural net is a one of the
most general form of neural network
because it can it is in fact the
sequential process machine
so at time step t
we start with the ht minus one that is
the memory state of the recurrent neural
net at t minus 1. so the previous time
step and then we have a recurrent
transition function g
which often is implemented as lstm or
gru and then this g is going to take as
input the previous memory state ht minus
one and then the current input xt
and computes the next time step ht
this g is parameterized with its own
primary theta
so you can imagine g as a function that
takes as input ht minus one xt and theta
in order to produce the newly updated
hidden state html
so so far so good and then why do we
call it recurrent neural network because
we're going to use this same block over
and over
as we receive more and more input so x
when we receive the x t plus one g is
going to produce h t plus one once after
that we're going to receive x t plus two
g is going to produce h t plus two and
then on and on and on and then what you
notice is that these two look exactly
the same and then in fact they have to
be same because i just copied and paste
one of them to the other and then you
have to just change the symbols and then
connected two more arrows on top of that
what that means is that if we can always
view a this kind of iterative
optimization procedure or the stochastic
gradient design or the gradient-based
optimization procedure as a recurrent
neural network on its own and then
weirdly so once we start looking at the
whole learning from this perspective we
notice that the gradient-based
hyperparameter tuning that we just
talked about is equivalent to training
this recurrent neural network that
corresponds to learning a neural network
[Music]
so
what that means is that we have to think
about how to train this recurrent neural
network but we're going to take a quick
tutorial to talk about
how
interesting when uh training a recurring
urinal can be
but before that there are two questions
let me try to answer those two questions
so the first question is from joel
guillermo
how do we choose the hyper primary
optimization hyperparameters
ah yes yes uh so the
yes we're going to talk about that
shortly so
i'll leave it there uh the other
question is from the and running what
are some of the references on the rnn
perspective for hyperparameter tuning um
my own paper i guess but you know this
is uh nothing new right it's just a same
thing viewed from a slightly different
angle
i mean i talked about it in my own
lecture and so on but i don't think
anybody necessarily wrote down anything
uh
too extensive about this particular
perspective
you know not everything needs to be
written down as a paper so but anyway
let's continue
um so the
when you think about the gradient-based
learning or training of a recruit neural
network we start we need to think about
it from what the loss function is and
then for now i'm going to just assume
that the every time step we take us to
input some observation and then we're
going to predict something at that time
step
and then for that one we have a
corresponding ground truth value so we
can compute the so-called per step loss
function
and then the loss function for the
entire sequence or the entire example
is simply the sum of this per step loss
functions
that's exactly what is shown on the side
then in order to update the parameter
theta of this recurrent neural network
we need to compute the gradient of this
total let's say sequence level loss
function with respect to the theta that
is the recurrent neurons parameters and
then we're going to update the
parameters little by little
what that means is that
what's most important is
to figure out how to compute this uh
gradient of the low sequence of the loss
function with respect to the recurrent
parameters
now it turned out uh this the recurrent
neural net has a very interesting let's
say structure that allows us to compute
this gradient of the sequence of a loss
function
in one of the two ways the first way is
i'm going to just call the future facing
is where we're going to consider
the loss function the c the gradient of
the sequence level loss function with
respect to
each and every time the
shared primary theta was used
so at time step s we are going to use
the shared parameter theta by making a
copy
and then use that to compute the loss
function i will to update the hidden
state first and then use that to compute
the loss function at time step t but via
because the hidden state is going to be
using the next time step the influence
of this
parameter copy at time step s is going
to
be
well it's going to happen all the way
until the end
so that is what we mean by the future
phasing every time we use the theta the
parameters at time step s we need to
consider how this parameter copy is
influencing the first of those functions
in the future that's the reason why we
call it future phasing what that means
is that at every time step in order for
me to compute the gradient of the
sequence level loss function with
respect to the parameter use that
timestamp s
i need to go
forward
and then back propagate the error signal
through time
two times the base so future facing view
is how is the usual way to compute the
gradient
uh
you know like in a prac in practice that
is we use the back propagation through
time
however
because
using parameters and time step and then
computing the per step low set this time
step is somewhat dual so you can view it
from the bottom up but for all the from
the top down you can actually have a
past facing view of gradient computation
as well that is we are going to look at
one particular loss function at time
step t
and then see how all the primary copies
from time step one up until that time
step and then see how they have
influenced this particular loss function
at time step t
and then to compute that we need to look
into the past that's why we call it path
facing
and then this actually is an interesting
view because this is not the view that
is most obvious for us like the modern
deep learners like including myself
although united this was obvious in 80s
and early 90s i heard yes
so just to summarize these two views
when we run a recurrent neural net and
then compute the per step loss function
and then sum all of them in order to get
the sequence of a loss function
we there are two ways to compute this
gradient
one is pass phasing that is that the we
try to accumulate the influence of the
all the past parameters on the current
time steps uh loss function and then sum
them all to get that gradient or we can
go the the other way that is the future
facing and every time we use a parameter
we're going to look at what kind of
influence we're going to have on all the
future loss functions and the back
propagates through time this error
signal in order to compute the loss
function and then after that we sum them
all
an interesting thing about the pass
facing view which is in fact the same
thing or the similar thing is that
probably the same thing as the
yeah same thing same thing as the
forward mode of the auto differentiation
this pass-facing viewer in fact admits
online learning in the case of the
recurrent neural network because at
every time step t
we can compute the gradient of the loss
function at the time step t with respect
to
all the applications of the theta
so we don't need to really look at what
are what are going to be received in the
future but we only need to look at what
have been received so far in order to
compute the gradient of the loss
function at time step t with respect to
the primary applications of all the time
steps which we can just sum in order to
get the gradient of the loss function
time step t with respect to the
parameter now obviously we just score uh
store all these copies and then sum it
that becomes the gradient of the full
sequence loss function with respect to
parameters but every term in this
summation never needed to wait for the
future inputs
and then the only thing that we need in
order to turn this into an online
learning is to update the parameters
immediately after we receive one input
at a time so we don't really wait for
every entire sequence and then update
the parameters but assuming that the
sequence is extremely long and then
relatively stationary we're going to
just make a small update to the
parameters as we go forward and then
this allows us to update the parameters
even
even before we receive the full sequence
and if the length of the sequence is
infinite then we're going to simply
continue to update the parameters online
so that the network can adapt
to the varying statistics the varying
underlying statistics
obviously it looks pretty expensive to
compute and then it looks like the
amount of the memory that is necessary
is not constant with respect to a time
steps in online learning if it's not
constant with respect to the
length of the sequence then it's
difficult to say that it's online
learning because your idea at the in the
infinite limit we're going to require
some infinite amount of the memory that
requires uh infinite amount of uh
compute time for access of course you
know we can be a bit
relaxed and say that yeah we're going to
go for the log n instead of the uh
o1 but that's still an issue if the n
goes to infinity
but it turned out that by cleverly
rearranging the terms and computing this
gradient of the per step loss function
at time step t with respect to the
parameters so far we can actually
maintain a constant memory storage
to compute this gradient on the fly
i'm not going to go into the detail it's
just a simple
not simple it's very confusing super
confusing rearrangement of the
terms but eventually all you need to do
is to maintain a so-called influence
matrix that tells us about what kind of
influence all the previous let's say
hidden state values and the parameters
have on the next hidden state
if i have to check out all those details
this uh so-called real-time recurrent
learning that was proposed by williams
and zipster in 1989
becomes a procedure of three line
so we update the influence matrix
compute the immediate credit that is
that the
laws are the gradient of the loss
function at time step t with respect to
the hidden state at time step t
and using this we can now update the
parameters using the gradient that is
carried over online and then we do it
over and over every time we receive a
new input
it's not widely used in practice that's
probably why most of you haven't
actually heard of it or at least haven't
used it even though you know you knew
about it because it's still quite
expensive in particular the issue is
with the memory complexity
it's often considered as onq
where the n is the number of neurons so
we're going to just consider a single
layer recurrent neural network and it's
fully connected so we have the n neurons
and then the number of the weights is n
by n so that is n square and as i said
what this influence matrix is carrying
over is
what kind of influence the hidden theta
times the t minus one and the weight
matrix is going to have on hidden state
at time step t
of course you can rearrange some of them
but still you end up with the n cubed
number of the entries in this influence
matrix
but obviously what that also means is
that
if the number of parameters of this
required neural net was constant with
respect to the number of neurons then
suddenly this real-time recurrent
learning is a very viable and perhaps
even
preferable solution to train our
recurrent neural network because we
don't have to wait all the way until the
end of the sequence
and in order to update the primaries
just once as we read the long sequences
we can just you know they update the
parameters on the flag effectively the
ratio of the number of updates per
sequence becomes let's say uh
the
is like significantly greater so perhaps
in this particular case this is going to
be very useful
now so we have learned how to train or
recurring your net in an online manner
is there any questions on this before i
talk about online hyper private tuning
which is a mid of this lecture except
that this is a very thin we're going to
just cover it very quickly um
so the i only see the draws question
that was from the previous let's say a
break uh yeah this one i'm going to get
to it soon the answer is it's a bit
difficult but i'll talk about it shortly
okay otherwise i'm going to go into it
now at this point uh it becomes a bit
uh let's say relatively straight for you
to see already what i'm going to end up
doing
what we notice is that did we know how
to train a recurrent neural network in
online manner and we notice that
learning with the stochastic gradient
descent or any kind of iterative
optimization is equivalent to running
the required neuron at once so then
we're going to combine these two
so that we're going to update the
optimization hyper parameters on the fly
and as soon as i said this united there
are a bunch of a couple of questions let
me try to answer that before i go in
so the anonymous attendee uh ask a
question
does this method allow for a dynamic
choice of hyper parameters meaning that
they are not constant throughout all the
inner optimization does this mean that
we have a larger hypothesis that this is
a great point in the sense that the
in of uh
unlike in a black box optimization
where we're going to
fix or the set choose one particular
hyper parameters configuration and train
our model all the way to the end and
then evaluate the validation laws we are
going to actually update the
hyperparameters on the fly what that
means is that it may actually change
as the training continues of course it's
a big question whether that's necessary
and whether it actually is helpful or
hurtful but we'll get to that uh in
terms of in the experiments a bit later
soon very shortly
so there there's a question from lev
mckinney is this the same as eligibility
traces yeah yeah it is very much related
to the eligibility traces and it's a
reinforcement learning summer school so
i'm not going to try to say anything
that is related to reinforcement
learning myself because i'm almost like
not even noticed i haven't even tried so
i don't really know much about the
reinforcement learning but this will be
a great question for you to ask to all
those rl lecturers later this week
let me see one last question before i
continue from anonymous attendee
what is the number of time steps in the
rnn do we consider a time step as an
iteration of training yes indeed we're
going to get to the reaction we got
there already on this side yes the num
so every time step in s3d so one update
is considered uh to be equivalent to one
step step in the recurrent neural
network in this particular setup but
again this is a perspective that we look
into how the learning is done or the how
learning should be framed doesn't mean
that this is the only way forward
all right so there's only 10 minutes
left so i'll have to continue a bit more
quickly so what that means is that the
uh
we can use this real-time recurrent
learning for training recurrent neural
net for the purpose of optimizing or the
tuning the optimization hyper parameters
as we train on neural network using
stochastic gradient descent because
training a neuron with a stochastic
gradient descent
is equivalent to running recurrent
neural net once forward
now
it turned out that we have some
expensive computation here because we
should be able to compute the jacobian
of the
hidden state of the recurrent neural net
that is the primary setup of the neural
network so the network parameter at time
step t with respect to the network
parameter at t minus one it's a gigantic
hessian
again we don't have to compute it
explicitly but we should be able to
compute this hessian vector product
there or the
uh the gradient hessian vector of so the
hessian jacobian product there
it's still expensive but
imagine you idea how it was before we
had to compute this hessian vector
product as many times as we apply the
sgd update to the neural network
for updating the hyperprimer ones but
here we just do it once every time we
update the hyperprimer so this is much
more doable although it's quite
expensive for a very large network
it turned out that for this particular
purpose
uh stochastic approximation or the
stochastic finite difference
approximation to this hessian vector
product works pretty well uh check out
this blog post by donkey justin donkey
uh and then it's a really short but cons
concise but very extensive let's say
discussion on what is the right way to
do this kind of finite difference method
to compute the same vector product well
so yes it is computationally feasible
why is that because often the number of
the hyperparameters we have is
significantly smaller than the number of
parameters or the network size and then
we often make sure that the number of
hyper parameters is independent from the
size of the network what that means is
that it's not really on cube but it's on
with a very small constant there is a
lambda square that is in front of this
end
and then you are the assuming that the
number of hypervenom is small enough is
okay
and even if we want to
use it for with a lot of hyperparameters
we can always go for computationally
cheaper and biased approximations such
as urobias online recurrent optimization
by talking all the va 2017.
so relatively straightforward uh again
if you have checked out all these you
know the uh let's say
low level details or the glory details
let me put it like that then it's a
three line or the three three step uh
procedure we update the influence matrix
we compute the immediate credit and then
we just update the hyper parameters and
we do it every time we receive a new
input and what is the new input here is
to receive a new mini batch of training
examples
so before i go into the experimental
research two major properties first one
is that it's fully online we really
literally update the network parameters
and optimization hyper parameters
simultaneously we don't like
uh let's say let's take a look at the
few more
mini batches and then go forward then
the backward we don't do that
we update
these two like simultaneously
every time we update the network
parameter we can update the optimization
hyper primers of course if we want we
can always
make them asynchronous if you want but
united generally we just use update both
of them synchronously and then the
second property is that it's almost
exact with a small enough metal learning
rate it is almost exact and well at
least india's symptoms
turned out uh we actually wrote a i
think a nice paper about this i put on
archives immediately to icml uh well and
then the uh the reviewers think uh
greatly pointed out that they we weren't
the first to come up with this idea
unsurprisingly there was a paper from
luca francesca all from 2017 where they
talk about this particular algorithm in
one one section of the paper
and then i looked at the paper thanks to
reviewers and the notice that okay this
is exactly the same idea i mean the idea
itself is really not not that dramatic
or you know the groundbreaking it's just
how we view the whole problem that's uh
that's what kind of let's say made it
really fun but it turned out it's the
same thing
uh except that they run they run only
one experiments but but because we
didn't know that uh luca did it we kind
of ran a very extensive set of
experiments to verify that this idea
actually works pretty well in practice
as well
so let's go into the experimental
details we have only five minutes so i'm
going to just finish off and then get
some questions
uh so we
ran an extensive set of experiments
although you know the only small very
small scale data says mnist and cfr10
and then we use a four layer fully
connected neural net for mnist and we
use reset 18 for c410 we use uh atom
optimizer although we did run the same
set of experiments with hdd without much
of the difference between these two
optimizers so first of all does it
actually work
if i compare it to the black box
optimization
can this
online hyperparameter tuning get to the
test loss
or the validation loss that is as good
as the most that we can find using the
black box optimization in one
sweep not even sweep right it's just a
one training run so we compared it
against a random search as well as the
baseline optimization with the scikit
opt and then we
ran it until the target test loss went
below 0.3
and then it turned out that the what we
proposed okay so we shouldn't really i
shouldn't really say it propose any more
but anyway this online hyper primal
optimization based on rtrl
were able to find or hit this target
in just one training run while for black
box optimization algorithms obviously
couldn't do it in one run i met it just
doesn't make any sense unless you get
super lucky and it require them many
many if the tens of the runs
so this actually
told us that it actually works
and then the stability wise uh this is a
this is connected to how to choose a
high performance optimization hyper
parameters and then one of the hyper
parameter hyperprimer optimization
hyperparameters is the initialization so
how do we initialize the hyper
optimization hyperparameters and then do
we have to be very careful about it as
soon as we have to be careful about it
the
use or the utility of this approach kind
of vanishes largely so so what we did
was to we
randomly vary the initial learning rate
we randomly write the regularization
coefficient we randomly vary scheduling
coefficients for for the atom or whatnot
and also the initialization of this
learning rate and regularization
coefficients and then what we have
noticed is that the
in almost all cases within one run it
was able to get to a very low test loss
with a very small variance
which was very uh interesting and you
know the uh assuring right
and what we what was most as exciting at
least to me was that as we increase the
number of hyper parameters so what we
did was that we started by using one
initial learning rate for or the one
learning rate for the entire network we
started to divide the network
layer wise and then you introduce more
and more learning rate and then what we
saw was that of course the world clock
time increased as the theory predicts
but at the same time the resulting test
loss
decreased almost monotonically which is
a
extremely good indication that this is
in fact solving this optimization
problem correctly
because more degree of freedom better
solution defines this has to be
rather indirect but still a very
convincing
evidence that this optimization actually
is solving optimization problem
and obviously one of the things that
online learning should be able to do so
is the adaptation so as the underlying
listing problem is perturbed or goes
through a change or the
distribution shift will it be able to
recover or adapt rapidly
we don't really have a good let's say
benchmark to do about uh test this uh
setup so what we did was to artificially
perturb the
hyper parameters in the middle of
training and then we saw if this online
hyper profile optimization can recover
from such perturbation
turned out they can really do so pretty
well and pretty rapidly
so because i really have only one minute
so i'm going to actually pass this now
one thing that i want to really uh
emphasize here is that the
there is a big question and then it
connects to the very uh the discussion
very early on is that does the choice of
the hyperparameters really matter in the
long run
if i start with a very large learning
rate in the beginning how much does that
actually influence the final solution i
find if i start with a very high let's
say regularization coefficients at the
beginning how does it actually influence
the future solution that i would get
after training for let's say
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
updates
and then
if there is such thing and then
that can only be captured if the
optimization algorithm is able to
capture it and the real-time recurrent
learning does not use the information
from the future so can it actually carry
over all those information to be used in
the future without knowing the future it
turned out that the answer is yes
if we
reset this influence matrix over and
over then the resulting test loss is
always higher
and then the best case test loss could
only be obtained only when we never
reset the influence matrix but carry
over in all the information that is out
there so it was a very interesting and
exciting let's say observation we made
so i'm going to skip through because
there are a few questions that i want to
answer as well
so one of the reasons why i decided to
talk about this at this summer school is
that it's not only about trying to use
the setup that has been proposed or has
been used by the community but trying to
see the same problem from a very
different perspective and then trying to
come up with a new framework and then
based on the new perspective often you
can actually come up with a new
algorithm that is not necessarily too
complicated or too groundbreaking but
just a clever well it's weird to call my
own work clever but let's say that
interesting and fun let's say a way to
reuse many of the ideas and according
from the same same same field as well as
the jsons field so it was really fun we
were able to make connection between the
recurrent neural net squash guardian
descent and the online learning in this
work to get to this online hyper primary
optimization
there are a few things that needs to be
considered studied in the future uh one
is that the
this one probably over should overfit to
the validation loss but we could not
actually see they over fixed the
validation loss per actually there is a
weird let's say interaction between
minimizing the validation loads and
minimizing the training walls we have to
work on that one
second thing is that the online learning
is only as good as you know the working
with the non-stationary environments and
then this is working uh we'll see how it
works in the true non-stationary
environments where the data sets shifts
the distribution shifts uh with the
infinite stream of the data and the
final thing is that they we do use
we use a lot of different let's say
hyper hyperparameters and then your id
was working okay but still as a hyper
primer such as a metal learning rate
growth the exact nature of the rtrl
grows as well so what does that actually
imply that kind of indexing is we need
to think about it finally final slide so
last week at icml one of the outstanding
papers was given to vicomet and sol
dixon dixon title unbiased guardian
estimation and unrolled computation
graph with persistent evolution
strategies this is really interesting
paper to read i still need to uh read it
more carefully and then digest it but
they actually
approach this problem of the online
optimization hyper parameter
and then you have to mix it together
with the evolutionary algorithm or more
of the uh
gradient-free optimization algorithm and
they showed that you can actually come
up with an unbiased approach to this um
i still i i always at this thing about
your idea oh well you know if i can do
the gradient free optimization why don't
i just use the gradient and make it
better but it looks like a very cool
paper and then if you're interested in
this online hyper primary optimization i
highly recommend you recommend you to
check uh check this out as well
well that actually concludes my talk but
let me try to answer a few questions
that are in the qa panel joel hopefully
i have answered your question so very
very stable within a reasonable range
but you know we probably need to get a
better sense of what the reasonable
range range is both theoretically and
empirically the set next question from
bradley brega
does one run of ohio take significantly
more steps than a single run increase no
actually the answer is no it turned out
that it doesn't take uh
more steps or is it sometimes more
sometimes fewer but not
that significant difference
from just training one run with a fixed
hyperparameter set
thanks far for organizing the whole
thing yes
[Music]
you